all right gabriel one two one two
gabriel yep where'd you grow up where
are you from originally uh originally i
was born in uh northern california
auburn i think my mom says somewhere
near folsom prison um and uh the first
place i remember though we moved to long
beach when i was a toddler she went to
cal state long beach so those my first
memories of like a place that i like was
home was growing up in uh alleyways and
really you know shitty housing and
uh like a lot of dumpster diving as a
kid and uh yeah a lot of like police
helicopters and gunshots and stuff like
that were kind of the noises of a home
like the earliest memories i have huh
and tell me about your
childhood in general um
i uh
my mom and dad were never married
although i was told he promised her he'd
always marry her i uh i like have him on
my birth certificate and everything but
my earliest memories they weren't they
weren't even together i was kind of like
split between the two of them and uh he
left when i was about four so like to me
you know in memory of life it kind of
seemed like right off the bat like he
was there and then he really wasn't i
have like really vague memories of him
and couldn't remember his voice for the
longest time
and uh you know my mom's always in my
eyes but like a single mother even when
she is with like a partner she's a very
strong independent woman so it's always
seemed like i've been raised by her
alone
she quickly married my step-father
sister's dad after that when i was about
four or five and uh he's actually the
one who got me into music and we got out
of long beach and got into like nicer
parts of orange county and i think we
lived in whittier for a while
and um my my second step that or my
first step that uh is funny because i
actually called him dad like he was he
stepped in so quickly that like with the
disappearance of my father he became you
know my my real father's in you know all
aspects
and um for all like these ways that i
loved him and i thought he was a really
great guy he had a real serious like
anger problem and abuse steroids i
believed and uh
was a brilliant musician it was it was
quite like this weird dichotomy of like
a muscle head meathead type guy but he
grew up in the 50s in la and was a
surfer and a musician and had like met
james joplin at the roxy or something
like that when he was 15 in the 60s and
he instilled all this like love for
music and culture and like art into me
and got me into writing at a really
young age but also like kind of imparted
this really intense uh like raising
style like militaristic kind of raising
style where
you know if something didn't really
happen according to his plan or law he
would
just kind of flip out and his episodes
that like his violent outbursts weren't
really so much like things that like i
feared it was like the kind of stuff he
did behind closed doors and
the like abuse i experienced with him
was uh was years from like ages like
four i'd say to about it wasn't until
about eight or nine they got divorced
and it was pretty much like yeah on a
nightly daily basis i was either like
physically verbally or emotionally
abused by him and
i like didn't really tie that into my
like my learning growing up as something
that was like bad necessarily because i
like had this intense love for him and
he gave me these gifts in my eyes like
he gave me music he gave me knowledge he
gave me you know a passion for learning
he he kind of like gave me
life like everything that i like you
know
thrive for and still have in my life to
this day and at the same time he gave me
like this
intense like hurt that i still carry to
this day and it's
it's uh i don't think the way i worded
it before somebody was i you know like
he gave me he gave me passion for life
and he gave me like passion for death i
have a couple thankfully on a you know
successful suicide attempts under my
belt but
through therapy i like have always been
able to tie them back to early childhood
abuse that always kind of stems from
something to do with him so yeah he's
kind of like the
the reason for everything that i love
and and hate most days but uh i've
worked through a lot of things and kind
of actually like learned to disassociate
you know what i do now from what i would
experience back then so and how old are
you
i'm now finally becoming an adult i
survived the 27 club uh so i can
actually be a real grown musician
and like survive and thrive you know i i
really didn't think i'd make it past uh
he actually thought i'd never make it
past 13. i never thought i'd make it
past 18 or 21 but uh after uh surviving
27 i think uh i'm actually i'm actually
going to maybe be a musician for the
rest of my life
at this point so you got into music
after i got a music he put a bass in my
hand when i was six years old i think
five or six i got a short scale like
tiny little carlo robelli bass
because i wanted to learn the buffy the
vampire slayer like theme song from a
movie or tv show i heard it was like
super metal and uh he was a bass player
so you know i had to be a bass player
they were the backbone of the band you
know guitar players were just chicks and
uh drummers were cool guys that hung out
with the band you know and nobody likes
a prima donna lead singer so you had to
be you know real musician a bass player
and
yeah
i started playing bass six and then i
started writing my own songs about
oh man i started writing my own songs as
soon as i could start like singing in my
head i started lyrics without knowing
they were really songs i would always
have a notebook as like early as i can
remember
my mom sang in the car i sang with her
and i really started writing songs about
12 13. when uh i moved to southern
louisiana my mom picked us up and moved
us out of la and got married to my
second step-dad my little brother's
father and i was suddenly a you know so
cowboy in the middle of the southeast
swampy louisiana and i was like a
foreigner in like you know a very very
strange land how was that it was it was
honestly it was a super intense culture
shock it really was uh people didn't
understand me because i spoke too fast i
had that kind of valley girl like the
abigail like rolling my consonants and i
had to learn how to like really slow
down and uh it was really nice for me
though because i think in doing that in
all aspects of my life learning just
slow down kind of take things that have
come and really listen more to people
and listen to myself how i was like
speaking and coming off people kind of
made me a lot more self-aware about you
know a lot of the
weird kind of knee-jerk coping
mechanisms that i developed through the
trauma in my life and
it was there that i really got into like
therapy and really music therapy through
my songwriting realizing like how i
could delve into like
kind of like things that i had
rationalized in a really skewed way
and see them on paper and kind of turn
that that that rationalization into like
understanding and realizing that it
wasn't really about pointing a finger of
blame or figuring out why something
happened but becoming just okay with the
feeling and being you know all right
with you know the things that had
happened to me and i don't know
hopefully through like music that i make
i can turn you know pain or confuse your
mind just into something that makes
somebody feel good you came back to la
when i came back to la after i'd done
some couple semesters at college at lsu
i was going for like theater didn't
really know what i wanted to do musical
theater something i got into high school
but i had a band right after high school
and going into college that like started
kind of picking up and doing well in
louisiana and i figured like why you
know break my back and go to pay i was
paying out of pocket to go to school
when i could be in a rock and roll band
and you know make some cheddar on the
side you know and not have to worry
about grades and just worry about chicks
and music so dropped out of school after
a couple semesters and uh did my band
for as long as i could until i figured
out that you know i was the only one who
really had the drive to like you know
take it all the way and i was shortly
after college whenever we started
settling down with their girlfriends and
getting married that i had to leave my
high school sweetheart you know just on
a whim and literally told her like i
love you but i have to go
packed up a car and my dog and drove
across
the u.s back to lay i like early mid 20s
and just was in a van playing in l.a on
the street busking uh was only alex
actually out here like a few weeks
before i met a guy who said he had a
whole band ready to go they just needed
a singer they had a gig at the whiskey
which was a lie there was like motorhead
music this and that whole lot of smoke
was blowing up my ass of course but
there was some truth to they had a full
band together and they these guys were
like really [ __ ] and musicians and that
really looked apart like drummer looked
like tommy lee guitar player looked like
angus and bass player looked like a
skinny heroined out duff but they could
actually play like those people too so
i somehow fit in there as like the weird
uh i don't know i got a lot of
comparisons like axel and sebastian but
i saw myself more as like a like a poor
man's like kurt cobain and robert plant
kind of smashed together and raised in
the south land
but uh yeah we we got our start at the
rainbow like things kind of started
happening really within a month of being
a band we had like a bunch of songs
written we started gigging at the
rainbow and the viper and all the strip
and
people were kind of starting to like you
know know us who went out to those kind
of places you know there are kind of
regular crowds but you know we were kind
of making a lot of noise so we uh we hit
a milestone at the rainbow and they told
us that
we they weren't going to book us anymore
they were having us twice a week and
they said we won't book you guys for
monday friday more until you promise to
bathe
apparently uh some waitress complained
about uh our van was called the trash
dog so i don't know what they expected
from the get-go but i i always saw that
as a win in my book
i told him you know i know who
complained and she knows she likes it
and we will not bathe and we will see
you on friday
so yeah played uh played with uh with
those guys up until just recently we uh
we did a record uh with a great producer
discovered us at the viper uh his name's
rocco he worked on uh some velvet
revolvers early stuff and their first
record um he pretty much did it all on
his own we recorded sunset sound we did
some stuff at a home studio in uh in
lafayette indiana uh we did some like
stuff like at our own home studio we
kind of recorded our record all over the
place but uh
it's really something i'm super proud of
i've never done a full rock and roll
like record and like had it actually
like come out you know be something that
that wasn't scrapped at some point
during the process
and uh while simultaneously doing this i
somehow in this rock and roll band uh
met my uh future like you know fiance
and
you know one of the greatest loves i
never thought i'd have another serious
thing after a high school sweetheart you
know that i was with for so long i met
uh
you know one of the loves of my life at
the rainbow uh she was underage and
sneaking in and i like the way my band
played and she wrote some songs too and
uh me and uh me and pk uh ended up
starting this band called the sound
flowers and while my rock and roll band
was kind of doing their thing on the
strip me and her were doing more of a
kind of like i would say you know major
route we got signed by lava records
which was through public records they
had like just signed green day or drake
or something like that and tried to
dangle that in front of us i think jack
johnson maybe and uh they're you know
trying to dangle this golden carrot in
front of us and we took no signing
bonuses or anything so we could own the
rights to our music and have complete
control and uh we got to choose our
producer which oddly enough we ended up
working with one of kanye west producers
his name is mike malakoff and we did a
really great ep that i'm super super
proud of a five song ep that's you know
all all just heart and soul that that me
and her poured into it pretty much it's
uh it's all like our broken shattered
like little bits of our lives that we
kind of strung together in this little
menagerie that i'm i'm really really
like grateful that i got to make
and uh
and for some reason i had all these
great great things going for me you know
i felt like i had uh i had like lost so
much and gained so much and come to like
a point in my life where i was kind of
okay with all the things that you know
that i'd been through and
i was engaged and like we were planning
on having kids and all this and my band
you know was we like showed our record
you know some people around duff
mccaigan actually heard it and was like
told rocco our producer like great a
[ __ ] real rock and roll band you know
and all these great plans and it was it
was i don't know funny that when kovid
came around and started happening uh it
kind of just seemed like my personal
life kind of started eroding with the
world
i let so many things that i felt like i
had a grip on just like come back and
erode my life like um
i've always kind of like danced with
opiate addiction and for once it finally
actually took like a grip and a hold of
me like i'd never known before i'd seen
friends become junkies but i'd finally
become like that person who you know i
couldn't even trust myself alone in a
room with a drug i didn't think and um i
i let it ruin my relationship my my
partner was getting clean and sober and
uh sober living she had already gone
through rehab we'd already been through
rehab together i was in rehab like for a
second time and the day i got out i went
to a truck stop and like bought an eight
ball and a needle and i i can't even
like really truly say why like you know
it almost feels like i chose to kind of
like to you know to
destroy almost everything that i had
going for me it felt right i think that
sadly enough it ties back to the same
[ __ ] that i've always you know kind of
felt as goes back to this childhood
feeling that i've known since like my
first like days of abuse is just like
if something doesn't hurt it doesn't
feel right to me it doesn't feel like
love it doesn't feel like home it
doesn't feel like
what i've known so i strive for that or
i seek it out or i make it hurt you know
and um yeah i think piece by piece i
kind of dismantled well this nice life
i'd built up for myself you know do you
blame covet or do you blame your i i
think hovid literally of course it's
it's me and you know that and all the
things that go into that but no i think
kovid was just the perfect setting for
it i think it was like kind of the
you know like um the excuse for yeah
yeah like the world was falling apart
you know so why not have my life fall
apart it kind of just i think it was
just like it opened the door it created
a setting in which it could easily
happen um because if before you know
things were going bad i could bury
myself in work you know i could plan
another tour or you know start a music
project and it seemed like everything
just kind of paused and like all we had
to do was kind of take a look at
ourselves and
i was with a partner who was
took a look at herself and wanted to
better herself for you know her life and
for me she wanted to be a better her
would be a you know a good wife for me
one day and a mother to our children and
i unfortunately took a look at myself
and decided that you know i still hated
myself and wanted to you know
not only continue to be miserable but to
almost uh
i don't know i think it's like that that
thing you talk about hey like you if you
don't hit rock bottom you just keep
digging until you find that until until
you hit that that hard you know that
hard cool down say pay dirt but it's pay
rock you know i hadn't found myself
truly between a rock and a hard place
and uh
unfortunately i i think these days i'm
pretty much just uh living there and
learning to cope with it i've been uh
been on the streets now for like uh over
about a year i've been homeless before
off and on but i've been like on the
street
like with or without a tent you know
various levels of uh you know like
currently today don't have a tent sold
my tent this morning so
i think it's as homeless as it gets i
don't know if i have a tarp even when i
get back to where i've been staying but
um i don't know there's um there's
something comforting in it where i feel
like
i can i can kind of actually honestly
rebuild and you know you know
truly like not
take a look at myself because i've
always had to do that you know
unfortunately every day but uh i i think
with my music with with my life with
everything here like i feel like i've
stripped everything away you know i've
stripped everything away i can i can
kind of guard myself with and kind of
build myself up with and now it's just
me
i don't have a guitar anymore guitar got
stolen out of my tent
i really just have like just me and the
truth and the you know
being uh you know the blank page every
day and it's um
it's daunting i was talking with with
ian who um it's a great musician who
really like gives me a lot of
inspiration and is the whole reason i'm
doing this with you now uh i was talking
with him the other day and saying how it
it really like music like songwriting is
kind of always my salvation
and i feel like now it's it's it's
lately at least it's been like this
heavy heavy weight and like a bummer it
sucks not creating without my partner
anymore without my you know without
without the love of my life that i've
had and it's this thing that almost like
is daunting and scary and hurts and for
some reason i feel like that's better i
feel like that's the best way for me to
create these days is to get to an honest
like you know truthful place is like
i've been saying like it's gotta hurt
i've gotta just like you know dig
through the pain and find something and
you know find my way out find me in all
of it and find you know
uh find like the the true me like
because i feel like i can't dance around
it i can't hide behind anything more i
don't have a band i don't have a group i
don't have a you know
a fancy you know name or anything like
that i just got a
four chords in the truth really these
days and
hopefully that uh that'll be enough to
get me you know
off off a hollywood boulevard
but uh getting in tune with your pain
might be
the best thing for your creativity yeah
i
i i feel like i've always acknowledged
my pain but i don't know if i've like
yeah if i've truly gotten to gotten to
know it and let it in like it's this
thing i carry along with me i drag along
like a you know like a bum leg i don't
know if it's something that i've truly
yeah like
kind of like i don't know i would say
they see it like weirdly but like gotten
intimate with and like been totally open
and with and you know been vulnerable
with it it's like being feeling pain is
a vulnerable thing in itself but i don't
think i've been vulnerable with my own
pain i think i use it like a shield and
like armor a lot
um and so yeah that's something you
can't really do on the street you can't
really
there's no there's no faking out here
there's no front in it like that that's
something that you know you get exposed
really fast so it's having to be like
brutally honest with myself and
truly with everybody that i meet
nowadays is uh
it's been really cathartic and it's been
it's been really eye-opening you know um
i always i grew up poor and thought i
thought i knew you know how the other
half lived and have lived you know some
some pretty lived in some pretty wealthy
parts of la and now that i've been in
some some of the worst i really feel
like i have a
greater appreciation for it for like the
life that i lived you know growing up
and
the even though i like you know
my earliest days were in shitty you know
apartments in long beach like i would
kill for that dumpster diving you know
back alley nowadays so it really puts a
lot of things in perspective and uh yeah
it's i'm just really grateful to still
be one of the ones who's uh alive and
still still out here because there's
countless people that i can aim who
aren't and
you know survivors guilt and all that
aside uh yeah i think just gratitude is
a big thing that i forget about in a
working pro working any type of program
you know having gratitude for the little
things and the big things too
what is your drug now
um my drug of choice now other than
self-loathing which it's always been uh
is mainly any opiate anything like a
numb numb me so that probably because
you're in the streets means fentanyl
yeah well yeah i was told it was it was
heroin starting off it felt like a
comforting thing to like a drug that
everybody knew about but yeah these days
it's these crazy scary like
you know i'm pretty much like i remember
uh back in the day when you go to
festivals there's like these research
chemical drugs that were going around
that were like acid but weren't and i
feel like like dope is like that now
like opiates are these weird chemical
research drugs you know nothing about
and can barely i went to detox once and
they told me like oh yeah you're not on
heroin when you're on car fentanyl and
fentanyl and a little bit of heroin i
was like what's this carfentanil stuff
is it for cars why is it in my body and
it's a yeah it's a pretty scary place to
be but honestly like uh until like i'm
ready to
to like like i said like fully address
like real pain issues
uh i don't know i'm gonna have to like
live with the day-to-day consequences of
living like this i
i um me and me and my buddy have talked
a lot recently though about getting back
into programs and he was doing detox
recently and for once i actually like
have a little bit of hope like going for
me in that era i've i've never been
never wanted to think about the future
and make plans i try to stay in the now
day to day but
i'm actually not staying in the now
day-to-day i'm just you know trying to
stay in that blank space you know in
between breaths and nods you know i'm
not actually trying to be present every
day so i'm for once i'm actually kind of
hopeful and uh
kind of like kind of like optimistic i
think maybe is
honestly the word that that there there
could be a day soon where i can just
live with my pain even though i have a
lot of physical trauma and emotional
trauma that i i would have to just deal
with raw i think like
i'm honestly getting to a place where
i'm not scared of it anymore i don't
know if it's
if there's strength or being able to do
it is really has anything to do with it
i think it's just
fear really has always kept me from from
taking an honest go at it were drugs
always something you played around with
or
i think i think so growing up like i
remember being in school and like doing
this thing with my eyes where i'd push
on them because i was bored in class and
not stimulating enough and it would make
me go blind like it would kind of get
the snowy fuzzy vision thing but it was
the crazy thing but i realized like i
was really tuning out and getting like
[ __ ] up like even in grade school
before i even knew what drugs were i was
finding ways to kind of change my
perception and alter my reality so yeah
i i abused like title pm when i was in
grade school too because it had like an
adverse speed like amphetamine reaction
to me um i remember being at a super
young age like really bad like i was
taking like half bottles at night and
girlfriends were worried about me
because i'd be on like three days
benders are not sleeping at like age 10
but uh yeah i think i've always in some
way
kind of like sought for something to
change the way you know i feel because
my natural state is
and more than just that pain like it's
what sits on top of it like i can
address it now and say pain but for the
longest time i thought it was anger i
always felt like this angry like mad
person even though i wouldn't show it my
father's hawaiian and i feel like that
half of me has always kind of been able
to remain cool and really calm on the
surface
like even right now i'm panicking and
freaking out but i'm not really
fidgeting too much i think it's sitting
here but i think that demeanor that i
that i've always had on the surface is
mass this like inner
fire that i've always felt and had and
it's almost like rage that has come from
some abuse that i've had but i it's only
been recently that i can truly like
unmask that and you know honestly look
at what that is because i really am not
like an angry person it's just pain kind
of you know disguising itself and coming
out different ways and uh
honestly that's the scariest thing to me
it's like admitting that is that anger
can be
oh it's channeled is definitely
definitely yeah and it's definitely an
outlet that i've like not like like to
let it come out as because i don't want
to see myself that way i don't want
people to see me i don't want to be that
makes me feel like the men i've been
raised by
and uh in the past like when that has
happened yet it's a it's just it
definitely is like an outlet that i feel
i feel like you know it's almost like
drugs it gets a whole lot out of you at
once you know it can be very cathartic
but in the end like it doesn't really
get me anywhere i found you know it uh
kind of leaves me back in the same place
where i started if not worse you know
how are you surviving on the streets now
uh i i bust when i can i honestly i have
an electric guitar right now that i'm
trying to get an amp for uh my acoustic
guitar was stolen
uh but like honestly just do what
anybody else does like like make a sign
fly sign panhandle you know do a little
three three shuffle three card shuffle
little shell games is this uh degrading
for
given where you were five years ago
yes i i would say at first maybe when i
first came out here it was the first
time i noticed somebody like looking
through me that was really hard to take
uh i asked somebody like what time it
was and this guy was a foot from me and
he like looked towards me but it was
like this dissociated blank like
thousand-yard stare and i repeated
myself like sir do you know what time it
is please and he really just i didn't
exist in his world i didn't he
couldn't you know he just couldn't even
acknowledge me not even with a word or a
look even and i've seen it like a
thousand times now and that's a hard
thing to it was a hard pill to swallow
you know coming from like paparazzi
screaming my name and
fans like crying when they met me to you
know somebody literally like putting me
in the blank space of their vision but
um it's kind of comforting away honestly
you know truthfully that to to come from
all that crazy hecticness to kind of
feel like you know i'm on the street
every day now almost to feel like i'm
hidden kind of in plain sight is nice
and to feel like invisible in some ways
it hurts a lot in a lot of ways like
just because of where i come from it's
it's a nice feeling for me though so
what emotion does it turn out
that you're dealing with most is it
depression or is it anger or is it uh
these days really yeah it's kind of like
just the
the
yeah that uh
the same self kind of loathing the
feeling of you know
i had i had something really great going
for me and not only did i let it go i
kind of like smashed the door in its
face you know and then took the door
apart to make sure that nothing else
could ever come through it and it's just
uh
yeah learning to like kind of accept
that and get over yeah just kind of get
over like like
forgive myself really for things that
i've done and kind of get the will to
get back up again and to do what i know
i've always been like put on this earth
and meant to do which is
create so other people can feel less
alone and feel better about going
through the same things that i've been
going through
to you know
to help me better relate and understand
with people and i think and at the same
time it from what i've heard from some
fans it helps them better relate with
themselves and also understand you know
me you know and people they meet with
the same kind of i know i don't want to
say like illness but like this i feel
like anybody who's moved by music has
this the same kind of little dna code
and bit soul that we all share which is
you know you you feel things sometimes a
little that that teenage girl never
really dies in you you're always a
little bit maybe too too emotional or
too dramatic or you know are you
self-destructive oh always always even
right now i had this beautiful rose that
i've like torn to shreds and is at my
feet um and just by nature i think uh
yeah my mother was a heroin addict and
got sober when i was born and she always
like told me stories about how she was i
never really saw it firsthand
uh she started drinking when i was a
teenager and quickly like eroded her
life and
got like you know into aaa immediately
crashed a few cars and duis and stuff
but like i didn't really see the true
like junky side of her i think like that
that depraved you know self-destructive
side i saw glimpses of it but i can
definitely see it now and through me
i've seen i have like the cool calm
demeanor of my you know father's you
know laid back hawaiian soul of me and
then i have the
punk rock you know girl that my mom
always was who's willing to you know
knock out their own front teeth just to
prove a point you know and uh
it's a it's it's it's something i'm not
too proud of these days i think like i
was when i was younger and trying to be
hardcore in punk rock uh being
self-destructive i don't think is that
cool the older you get when you actually
start like destroying yourself and it
hurts the next day you know
um but it's something at the same time
like i am
i kind of wear like a badge of honor
it's uh i'm really am like grateful and
proud of where i've come from my mom's
always trying to install instill that'd
be to remember where i've come from and
i think when she says that i think she
honestly means to like be proud of it
and to like represent it and be honest
and true to myself because of that and i
think i'm learning to do that a lot more
these days because i'm i'm back where i
come from and i'm you know having to
deal with all the
actions and reactions and you know
result of where i've come from and the
the person that i think i've always been
and hopefully one of these days i can i
can learn to put that down on a song and
be okay with it
what do you think would have happened in
your life if
covet hadn't happened and you hadn't
self-destructed
and you became wildly successful in
music
you think you still would have found a
way to self-destruct oh
death i think it would maybe probably
made it easier but who knows i mean
yeah with
pre-covered
yeah things were
yeah it's hard to say i mean hopefully
there there is a parallel reality where
you know i did get married and and had
two two sons with the love of my life
and you know we continued to make music
and were like fleetwood mac except less
you know like sexual experimentation
with multiple partners and a lot a
little bit more monogamous than they
were but uh
i i like to say i
the the relationship that we had i feel
like is like the tragedy of most
hollywood relationships which is
too much outside kind of interference
and you know hearsay and just people
creating their own reality and that kind
of bleeding into yours
we always tried to like from the start
like tried to shield ourselves from that
but unfortunately it all it crept in and
in the end was kind of the you know the
death of both of us it was it was
the outside world and
you know the the lies that that kind of
stem up and not like viciously just like
naturally people not understanding and
you know creating their own version of
things and that kind of almost yeah like
influencing both of our our hearts and
minds and
kind of poisoning the well and so to
speak and uh see i think maybe it was
doomed from the start
we were star cross lovers who were you
know
tragic from the get-go but i like to
believe there
there's a there's a galaxy far far away
or somewhere out there where it worked
out and you know i'm i'm i'm a good
father somewhere
so you have two kids
uh no unfortunately that was the plan we
we did the whole nine picked out baby
names and everything we were planning
the wedding and i had the kids no never
had the kids uh knock on some type of
wood um no i have a i have a dog i have
fur baby uh fred who's the trash dog's
namesake uh other than that yeah i
raised my siblings and that kind of
feels like a nice little fatherhood
badge
my little brother is like 13 years
younger than me my sister is five years
younger than me and i was making her
breakfast and brushing her hair like
but before i was even double digits you
know so
it's a i feel a little a little
gratified and satisfied that i have like
two little little people that that have
like a big chunk of me in them and
they're they're a lot better than i
could ever hope to be smarter and wiser
and funnier and just you know
kind of like the best parts they'll tell
you it's the worst parts you know all
their shortcomings are my fault but so
yeah i don't feel like i've missed out
too much in uh and not having kids i
definitely feel like i missed out on you
know the the love of my life but
i also got to experience the love of my
life so maybe i didn't actually miss out
on anything
what do you worry about now
what do i worry about now
uh you know
rain getting into my tent or target but
like more and more seriously no except
what are you afraid of
uh honestly what i'm truly afraid of is
is
is doing what i've been doing kind of
i like you know i'm still
trucking on but it really feels like
i've uh if you i think if you ask
anybody who knows me it it looks and is
honestly it's like i've given up it's
like you know i'm not
i'm not making music for for me for
anyone else anymore i don't i think i've
truly written something in like the
longest that i this is the longest i
think like
like writer's block i think or gap that
i've had since i've started creating
music and uh
i i don't i don't know i
i look i feel like i'm looking for
something to to kind of you know spur me
back back in like back into falling in
love with music again you know i'm
always going to love it but i feel like
it's that sad thing happens
relationships when you're not in love
with your lover anymore and uh yeah
unfortunately i feel like i'm at that
point with my music right now where it's
it's
so there's been so much hurt between us
that i don't know if they're like that
that love is there anymore i'll always
love her but i don't know if i'm in love
with her and you think your addiction
might be playing around 100
i uh anytime i get any type of sobriety
under my belt i'm like amazed like how
how the songs come flying out of me last
time i was in rehab i wrote like six
songs in a week or some stupid thing
like and they were all
fantastic like all record worthy and
yeah it definitely definitely has
something to do with it and then i trick
myself though at the same time because
i've written some of the best songs i've
ever written like you know in in opiate
you know just driven you know depression
stages you know wallowing for for months
on end you know that's somehow eeked out
some songs before but yeah definitely
like 100 like
the the addiction struggles that i have
are
are like the one thing keeping me like
waking up in the morning now every day
you know and at the same time like
keeping me almost like you know in bed
you know metaphorically and not actually
getting on with my life and moving
forward and doing anything and uh i i
it's really just i gotta
i got i don't think i'm looking for a
person place or thing it's you know it's
hard to say what that spark is musically
you know what inspires you but that i
think that's what it is i'm looking for
like
that great flash and spark and
flash in the sky that's gonna you know
make me just just want it again feel it
again i don't know what what the actual
word or emotion is it's just like i said
that love i it's it's mostly hurt and
you know pain and fear and
you know a whole just a whole lot of
whole lot of life that that's
come from it and i feel like has just
like died from it like i built up a
whole life and then just tore it all
down and now i'm at this place where
it's like do i really just start over
and build up something you know erect
another structure just to tear it down
again or you know do i do this for real
or what what is you know what is
actually for for real building a life
these days is it worth it um
you know before passing 27 i was just
like you know screw it i'll just do as
much as i can write as many great songs
i can and just [ __ ] go out at 27 and
let it be set in stone you know i was
just one of those that'll be easy
and now i'm unfortunately like tasked
with with the the struggle of leading a
life living life building a life
possibly probably on my own and
four for myself for once and uh that's
the scariest thing i think i've ever
been posed with that and and the daily
blank white page as i call it the uh the
struggle of like taking what i'm going
through and
you know
sadly to say like trying to make it art
that sounds like so
stupid and trite like i have to i have
to turn
you know like uh
waking up breathing and eating and doing
all this [ __ ] into art somehow but
that's the that's the struggle i think
of being a musician is like trying to
make it feel like it's all worth it
trying to make it feel like it's all
it's maybe more important than it is
when um i don't i don't really think at
the end of the day it's really that it's
just it's just being honest the music
that moves me the most is some of the
simplest stuff that kind of captures
this little moment that that ring so
true to me and feels so familiar and
like
just kind of feels like home maybe or
you know it invokes something that i
just like i can totally identify with
and i know that person is not full of
[ __ ] for once i only hope i can do that
for a moment and then my music
all right
thank you so much for sharing your story
and uh we should have a look out there
man appreciate you thank you this is uh
yeah this is great thank you very much
you